[Music]
and see how we're meeting each other we
meet in the middle
[Music]
it's hidden because you're not doing
self-defense techniques you're doing fun
okay so when I do this movement this is
the movement right it comes in a million
places he goes to both my waist right
[Music]
we're just doing it now for the strap
attempt but you see how my arms are
coordinated with each other so I'm
passing them to the other sword okay he
comes in wool wool don't have your
swords independent everything's in front
of you everything is in front
[Music]
so FG coordinated obviously it's given
y'all okay they can't be doing it their
own thing they work they work together
they work with the four corners they
work with the ground table then
obviously they have to stay inside my
outer rim I don't defend this area out
here
okay then there's a kind of you need to
pass through this progression where you
have an elbow power not wrist power okay
so I'm making you use your elbows he
comes in boom that's my elbow and then
he's gonna hit the inside of this elbow
so you can think of the technique is
passing elbows okay so boom to that
other level the outside of one elbow the
inside of the other elbow outside so
everything is very tight inside the
outer rim I like this
also don't let it go by I already went
by you this is now independent elbow it
passes it you see it's right here he
comes in Mughal slope boom there it is
can't go like this past it in essence
what I'm doing he does the boob again is
I'm going out and it you see that out in
not like this so in the out in I have
the other arm boom so out